[MUSIC PLAYING]
DIANA SAVIT: I did
not think, very much,
about what would Jewish
life be like, there.
ARIEL FUTTER: I really wanted
a strong Jewish community,
but not something so big
that I would get lost in it.
SHILPA NADIMPALLI KOBREN:
When I came to Princeton,
I was not Jewish.
BENJY GERUT: I had the option
of choosing which Rosh Hashanah
service I wanted to go to.
SHIRA COHEN: I knew
that being Jewish --
and being Jewish at
Princeton, and beyond --
was incredibly important
to me before I got here.
I just didn't know
what that meant.
LEN BERMAN: And I remember,
when I was applying there,
when I'd go there -- and,
I think, plenty of people
have his experience -- it's like,
what nice Jewish boy would
go to Princeton University?
There was still a difference
between people's perceptions
of the University, and
the reality of what
it was like to be Jewish there.
DAVID LANGER: My grandfather,
Marcus Lester Aaron,
Class of 1920, wrote,
during his time
at Princeton from 1916 to 1920.
JULIA LANGER: "For the
last six or eight weeks
a few of my friends
have been meeting here
in my room regularly every
Friday evening for service."
DAVID LANGER: "I think I
can say, without the slightest
exaggeration, that there can be
no more broad-minded institution
of higher learning, or any other
kind of learning, anywhere,
than Princeton.
JULIA LANGER: In one of
the letters from November
of his freshman year, he talks
about hanging up his banner
for the first time -- his
class banner, in 1920,
and it's hung in my
dorm room every year.
It's a nice reminder
of one of the reasons
why I wanted to come to
Princeton is tradition.
ARIEL FUTTER: My grandfather's
first cousin came to Princeton
in the early '50s, after
surviving the Holocaust,
when hiding in a monastery.
And then came over to
Paterson, New Jersey,
and decided to
apply to Princeton,
and persisted after being
told that Jews don't really
get in there.
And then he came here
in the early '50s.
JAMES GREILSHEIMER:
The objective
of 100%, which I believe
started in the 1940s,
after World War II, was to
prevent a situation where
some members of a class would
not be selected for any club,
and would therefore not have a
full social life at Princeton.
MARK BIDERMAN: Every club
had to interview everybody --
once or twice, I think,
was the rule at that point.
And then they'd
slowly cut people.
JAMES GREILSHEIMER: I was a
member of the sophomore Bicker
Committee.
And I saw that, the people
who were not getting bids,
that a large number of the
people in trouble, were Jews.
MARK BIDERMAN: You
know, and I only
got a bid from one of them,
which was, at the time,
considered in the lower tier.
JAMES GREILSHEIMER: And
I thought that something
should be done about it.
And I went public with it.
These clubs were
really a very important,
an integral, part of Princeton.
And, therefore, it was part of
Princeton as an institution,
and that discrimination
should not be allowed.
And I said to President
Goheen, this is just wrong,
it cannot be tolerated, it sends
out the wrong message about
Princeton, everywhere.
And something should be done.
And you're the person to do it.
I mean, almost, I'm reliving
some of that conversation.
I mean, done in a
very respectful way,
but there was no
missing my meaning.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARIEL FUTTER: For me, thinking
about what the Orthodox
Jewish community looks
like was really important,
and what daily services
were going to look like,
and how large those
were going to be.
DIANA SAVIT: My first
year, before Stevenson Hall
opened with the kosher facility,
the kosher dining option
was to eat at Yavneh
House, off campus.
ARIEL FUTTER: In the orthodox
community, we call it Yavneh.
And it's been around for
over 50 years, at this point.
TOBY ROBISON: Of the
early years of Yavneh,
were on Olden Street.
But they had moved closer
to us and 46 Wiggins.
Then they had this kosher
house, and it was very nice.
It wasn't exactly
University rules.
There was one cook who
provided all three meals.
And if you came to
morning services,
you were invited to
stay to breakfast.
DIANA SAVIT: It was
a very small group,
largely graduate students.
And I felt I was really
being removed from my peers,
and I wasn't forming a community
with other students on campus,
Jewish and non-Jewish.
Because, mostly, you form
a community with the people
you eat with, and live with.
ELAINE ROBISON: If you had a
kosher eating house on campus,
supported by the
University, that
would be a magnet
for undergraduates.
TOBY ROBISON: But then, the
University put a lot of money
into setting up a kosher
dining hall at 83 Prospect.
And in return, they demanded
that the Jewish community
come up with 40-meal contracts.
DIANA SAVIT: When Stevenson Hall
opened with a kosher facility,
it was one of only
three universities
in the country where
you could eat kosher
in a university-sponsored
facility,
the other two being the Yeshiva
University and Brandeis.
So, of course, it immediately
became very attractive
to more observant people.
KEITH KRIVITZKY:
Stevenson Hall was
a place where tons
of people came,
who weren't a part of
the Jewish community.
And it was a warm,
welcoming place.
TOBY ROBISON: So it made an
enormous difference to come,
to the students who,
otherwise, would
have been happy to be eat their
TV dinners that were kosher.
BENJY GERUT: There's
a quiet comfort
when you have certain pieces
of life that are in place,
especially as a Jewish person,
if it comes to kosher food,
when it comes to religious
events -- prayer, things
like that.
When those things are
there, you can really live.
ARIEL FUTTER: So an
eruv is an enclosure.
It's, in many ways, like
a fence or a doorway.
And what the University
has been amazing to do,
is to, in many respects,
create that enclosure,
so we can feel part of it,
and contribute and benefit
from Princeton as a whole.
BENJY GERUT:
Princeton has an eruv.
That's really beautiful.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
WILLIAM G. BOWEN:
It just seemed to me
that the University would be a
much richer, better learning
environment, if it had
a variety of people
from different backgrounds,
different points of view,
interacting easily and
comfortably with each other.
And that has not always been
true in Princeton's history.
In our proper
effort to celebrate
the successes of Jewish
students at Princeton,
over many, many years, we should
recognize that it's not always
been an easy path.
I mean, there were
Jewish quotas that I
was very well aware
of when I came here
as a graduate student.
So there was not a
very nice history.
And so, it seemed to me,
important to do something
about that.
I became particularly
aware of this problem,
at the undergraduate level,
as a result of teaching.
As I talked with
Jewish students,
I became aware that they really
did not feel, in all respects,
comfortable at Princeton.
They felt isolated and
really not at home, fully.
ARIEL FUTTER: When
my dad tells a story
that students put together
a proposal saying,
let's create a space
for Jewish services
on campus, that might be
a little bit for bigger
than what they had a
Murray-Dodge, at the time.
So they put together a
proposal for a Hillel center
in Chancellor Green,
and presented it
to President Bowen.
And President
Bowen, at the time,
said that he liked the
idea, but that wasn't where
they were going.
But felt that there
was an obligation
that Princeton had to
foster Jewish life,
and had a historical obligation.
LEN BERMAN: So I
woke up one morning,
and went to get The Daily
Prince sitting outside my door.
And I remember
seeing the headline --
Shapiro named president,
or something like that.
And I just stared at
it, almost in disbelief,
that they picked
a Jewish guy to be
president of this University.
HAROLD T. SHAPIRO: A new
kind of tiger is arriving,
and I wasn't quite
sure what they meant.
From the Jewish
community's point of view,
yeah, they were very excited
that I was appointed president.
They were also very worried.
Why are they worried?
They're worried
that I might fail.
Right?
And how would this
reflect on them?
Once my appointment
was announced,
it was very clear that many
Jewish alumni, in particular,
wrote me letters saying, how
important this was to them,
they never thought
this would happen,
that they didn't
imagine that Princeton,
in the fullness of history,
would ever get to this point.
So, for example,
I think the person
who actually, eventually,
provided the money
for the Center for Jewish Life,
this was the reason he did it.
He didn't do it for
any other reason.
He just said to me, if
Princeton can change that much,
then I can support them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DARCIE DUBOIS: The community, here in
the CJL, is very tight.
And it just feels very
comfortable, and very much
like home.
RABBI DARCIE CRYSTAL: I was
among the class that
was the first to benefit from
the Center for Jewish Life,
for our entire four
years on campus.
TOBY ROBISON: When
CJL was built,
it was the first
University building
you would see as you drove up
Washington Road, toward campus.
SHILPA NADIMPALLI
KOBREN: The CJL
had a really big role in making
Princeton feel like home to me.
Now, I've undergone a
conservative conversion --
two years ago, now -- with
everyone singing together,
and people who were
there to celebrate me.
That's a really when
it really hit me,
that this is the moment.
This is what means a lot to me.
MAYA WAHRMAN: We don't
all have to agree
or practice our
Judaism the same way.
But there's a place
for all of them.
MASHA SHPOLBERG: I
didn't know that there
was such a lively
community, with so
many different Jewish
backgrounds represented.
So that was a great thing
to discover, upon arrival.
And it actually changed my
perception of Princeton.
SHILPA NADIMPALLI KOBREN:
Every Friday night,
after Shabbat dinner,
everybody would get together --
either at the Chabad
House, or Hillel,
or somebody's house on
campus, or off campus --
and just have
discussions about like,
what are the ethics of this,
and how do you feel about this.
In that sense, it felt like,
community is a big part
of a lot of religions.
But for me, for Judaism,
that was Judaism.
BENJY GERUT: Neither
Chabad, nor the CJL,
or the Jewish
community, generally,
would be where it is without the
University's efforts thus far.
But my hope would be, that
the University continues
to want to integrate,
as much as possible,
these things -- in
a way that allows
them to completely flourish.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KEITH KRIVITZKY: I really want
to acknowledge Jim Diamond --
Rabbi Jim Diamond.
His passing was a tremendous
loss for the Jewish community,
and for the
University community.
He was an amazing thinker, a
mensch -- someone who's just
a great person, all around.
RABBI DARCIE CRYSTAL: Rabbi Diamond was
somebody that I looked up to.
I always saw him as a mentor.
And, I think, he
really encouraged me
in terms of my own
leadership, and in terms
of pursuing a career in the
rabbinate after Princeton.
MAYA WAHRMAN: There are
so many rich opportunities
for learning about Jewish
texts, about Jewish history,
and just getting a much richer
picture, of not only what
Judaism is, but
how I would want it
to interact with my own life.
MARK BIDERMAN: I think the
University's commitment
to the program has
been fantastic.
And I think the
involvement of the faculty,
and now the younger
generation of faculty --
which is so impressive -- was
started by a corps of faculty,
now many of whom have retired.
And there's a whole new
cadre, which is just terrific,
to see it grow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER:
I had an amazing discovery
when I was helping my son
with a family history project.
Found out that my
mother, who had
kept this secret throughout
her life, was Jewish,
and that I was Jewish.
And that's been a very
meaningful discovery for me,
in my life.
And it certainly has affected
my relationship to Jewish life
at Princeton.
In my first year as
president, the students
invited me to participate
in their all-night talk
show, which was called the
All-Nighter with David Drew.
And they had found out
about my recent discovery
that I was Jewish.
And so they asked me whether or
not I had been bar mitzvahed.
And of course, I hadn't.
And then they bar
mitzvahed me on stage,
in a wild, three-minute
celebration,
that took all the main elements
of a Long Island bar mitzvah,
and brought them on
to a Princeton stage,
and condensed them.
At the end of it, they were
hoisting me up in a chair.
They were having fun.
I was kind of having fun.
Their parents were very
worried, in the front row,
that they were about
to drop the president
of the University on the stage.
But it was one of the
most memorable experiences
that I've had as a
Princeton president.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER:
It's wonderful to be
able to celebrate 100
years of Jewish life,
and recognize all that's
happened in the past.
We are recognizing that we have
a lot of traditions that we
have celebrated for a long
time, at Princeton, and newer
traditions, and ways of thinking
about the institution, that
are equally meaningful,
and add to the Princeton
that we are today, and
the Princeton that we
want to be in the future.
I think this conference
is a special opportunity
to make that happen.
[MUSIC PLAYING]